this there is the fine line right
between talking [ __ ] and and backing it
up but you know you you you did a great
job of pissing people off in your career
and that is that plays a factor that
whatever you can do to get just them a
little bit out of their comfort zone a
little bit out of their composure I and
you you were really good at that
yeah you know you know I mean I hate
that to be you know the first thing
people say about me but you know what's
one it was it was a thing you know it
was what I did and in my mind you know
where I come from my background you know
if we're gonna fight then we're gonna
fight and then it's all-out war you know
and until it's all said and done and if
I can make you doubt yourself if I can
you know it's like at the weigh-ins at
the ways that's the last time you're
gonna get a chance to stand in front of
your opponent and send a message to him
you know remain and if you get in his
face and you can just instill a little
fear puff your chest that's why animals
do it in the wild you know what I mean
puffy chest out look intimidating look
as angry as you can you know and and
some fighters might just look at that
and laugh and said this ain't gonna work
on me
but some it does yes and then and then
they don't fight to the best of their
ability because they're slightly
doubting themselves and they're not
fully committed to the punch or the kick
and if they're not fully committed
they're not 100% they're not fighting as
well as they can be and I'm winning that
bow you know so yeah you look like kind
of a thug standing up there and pointing
your finger and talking [ __ ] but it's
for a reason you know it works yeah and
there was its McGregor McGregor is the
best at it you know yeah gets people to
fold look at Dustin Poirier did he show
up in that first fight it's true you
know and yeah I mean don't get me wrong
he was great as well you know it wasn't
just the trash talk hmm no he's great as
well I think the Nate Diaz fight didn't
it didn't work in that fight yeah Nate
doesn't give a [ __ ] doesn't give a [ __ ]
there you go doesn't work exactly it
doesn't work and talk [ __ ] at him he's
like [ __ ] you it doesn't yeah it doesn't
make him feel bad at all I enjoyed it
exactly comforting yeah well you know
just another day at the office you know
it's uh it's the thing like a lot of
people would wish that fighters were
respectful and just you know treated it
well the martial-arts way and bow to
each other and that's great it is you
know it's funny I was working out this
morning and the gym manager he said he
said you know I said I feel like that
side of things kind of you know it's
killing the UFC you know I nodded away
and like you know respectful to the guy
but I I see his point I understand what
he's saying but it's entertainment and
he gets people that that's another
reason why I used to do it you try to
sell the fight you know what you want
you want every product you're involved
with to be as popular as possible
whether it's a podcast whether it's
fighting whether it's well whatever it
is if no one's watching no one gives a
[ __ ] then you're not gonna make much
money you're not gonna get bucked again
you're not gonna be on the big cards you
talk a little I know from a consumer
standpoint if I'm watching a fight I
mean look at that last week with their
fury and wilder yeah you know I was
eating out the palm of their hands I
mean it was an amazing fight but you
know it hypes it it's great it's awesome
to watch I mean yes it is beautiful to
see two fighters walk up there and bow
and shake hands and all the rest of it
but it's also a little [ __ ] boring if
I'm honest like when I'm working the way
jaws I'm like give me something to talk
about ladies you know cuz I don't want
to talk about your boring last fight
that went to a split decision and when
nothing really happened but if you get
in their face at the way I'm great we
can pump it up a little bit we can sell
the fight we can hype it up yeah when
they have these press conferences and no
one's being mean at all I mean half the
fun stuff yeah [ __ ] yeah absolutely
you know I'm enjoying myself I'm in my
element of them it's like that you know
the famous form of GSP when is are you
intoxicated you know you don't want to
fight until the end of the year and it's
January okay if we were fighting in two
months
I wouldn't mean toxicated but right now
I am you know so yeah well there's been
some hilarious moments and in press
conferences I mean the one the giant one
with the UFC where Jeremy Stephens close
out the Conor yeah that was hilarious
that was great it really was good
honestly every time I see that I do
laughs it was great oh he had to say
yeah he's that guy
is it but I don't know but I think he
was actually actually serious
hey my [ __ ] is this guy but I'll let me
out talking [ __ ] where he knows who
Jeremy Stephens no no you don't think so
maybe maybe not maybe not I don't know
everybody up there sometimes that press
conference is yeah you can't you know in
a MAME do you have see has more than 500
fighters in their roster a